greed a culture of secrecy abuse
crispinudi was one of Britain's
wealthiest men and one of its most
successful hedge fund managers he was
this bygone figure from the bygone era
he started to stroke my leg under the
desk I did not want to be alone with
this man
he has continued to behave like this
he has been protected it's been one of
the quickest and most decisive
unravelings of a hedge fund that I can
remember
it wasn't the company that assaulted the
women
he is the one who needs to be held to
account
[Music]
Chrisman Odie is or was a very high
profile financier the hedge fund
Maverick one of Britain's wealthiest men
and one of its most successful hedge
fund managers he harks back to a time
when the hedge fund world was a cottage
industry predominantly running money for
high net worth individuals you typically
had these intense charismatic Larger
than Life characters who had their name
on The Door Odessa management is the
firm that Chris Bernardi founded in
1991.
it's one of the UK's oldest hedge funds
the last kind of Bastion of that 1980s
World of Finance the really like
red-blooded Unapologetic money making so
he's known for making some very clever
bets on markets over the years as well
as some poor ones he would take these
hugely risky punts on the world based on
how he saw it and where he saw it was
going some people have said that he's
Blended his financial and his political
interests a little too closely
it's the financial crisis that really
cemented odie's reputation as an
investor he started shorting the UK
banks in 2007 which is betting that
their prices would fall this would prove
to be extremely prescient and he made a
killing during 2008 when the world was
in financial collapse one of our sources
told us about this meeting where Crispin
walks in and tells them all to short the
banks and they're sitting there
flabbergasted that was part of the
process that should have been carried
out but also completely captivated by
this Maverick kind of brilliance
odie's also been a prominent political
donor both to his friend Boris Johnson's
leadership campaign
foreign
campaigns after brexit he shorted the
pounds at least for a little while saw
an enormous gain like hundreds of
millions of pounds he would go for lunch
in the creme de la cram of mayfair's
restaurant Scots the gabbrosh the Connor
Hotel
Harry's Bar corrigans and he sort of
represents this era where you go for
these long boozy lunches
come back slightly suzzled still at it
you're still trading and some days that
makes you millions and some days it
doesn't the staff there would were
effectively nobility he had Dukes
marquises VI counts Earls ads management
feels like
um a sort of boys Public School a gun
cabinet saw your gun before the shooting
weekend but the world has moved on and
he hasn't he's enormously influential
but he's also massively abused the power
that he's had
in 2020 Chrisman Odie was charged with
one count of indecent assault
the trial was held in a Magistrate's
court which was a big win for odie's
defense and decided by a judge rather
than a jury
he was cleared and the judge told Odie
that he could walk out of the courtroom
with his good character intact
and the judge also heavily criticized
the complainant so he said that she had
a vivid imagination and suggested that
she was influenced by her desire for
publicity shortly after Odie was
acquitted in court the Sunday Times ran
a piece saying that a woman said he had
grapes her in a restaurant in 2008 a few
weeks after the Sunday Times article
came out Bloomberg ran a piece saying
that he had sexually harassed two women
including an employee
Odessa Management Open investigation
into him they kept the financial
Watchdog the financial conduct Authority
abreast of what was going on they found
that he had violated a final written
warning they gave him they wanted to
begin a disciplinary proceeding against
him because of it and instead Odie
sacked his executive committee brought
in another when that other executive
committee also refused to drop the
disciplinary proceedings he sat them too
so the current executive committee at
early Asset Management other third and
they told the FCA that he was they
thought he was fit and proper and the
FCA has been aware of this it all just
seemed to kind of wash off him so for
the next 18 months there wasn't any more
negative for us until December 2022
tortoise media published a podcast
[Music]
according to her evidence he lunged at
her and was all over her like an octopus
she said that she was then forced to
wrestle him off and run out the door
for me the story started in October 2022
around the time of lestrasse's mini
budget
her Chancellor was quasi-quarting soon
before quateng was made Chancellor he
went to crispinuri's private house in
Chelsea for a private lunch my editor
saw this and thought there's a real
problem here a really big hedge fund
manager courting the business secretary
whoever unexpected to be the chancellor
and radically change the economic policy
of the UK he told me there's one woman
who I know had an issue with Chris
benudi
I met this woman she told me Chris
benody assaulted her at a restaurant
about 13 years ago quite quickly that
one woman became five someone who's
lunched with him for many years says
that crispinudi is a man who whatever
the temperature sweats I listened to the
podcast I thought it was brilliant it
was accidentally reported really
thorough they had loads of evidence
you would hear these accounts from
different women who never spoke didn't
know each other worked in different
fields lived in different countries some
of them yet the way they made their
allegations oversold it was like looking
at the fingerprint you know it was the
same the lunging the tongue the groping
it didn't have the impact certainly the
women who gave us interviews for this
podcast were expecting so there was no
regulatory intervention it was like
nothing happened it all just seemed to
bounce off Crispin yet again none of it
hit home just two months later his firm
was awarded management firm of the Year
these very glitzy hedge fund Awards by
December 2022 eight women had come
forward with allegations about Crispin
ODI either to the police or to other
media groups
in the meantime myself and Antonia
started trying to find new sources
ourselves you just feel like there is
likely to be a huge amount more out
there but we just decided that we would
do it deeper but we want to pause hell
because Paul had had new sources come to
him post podcast we got the ft to agree
to let us team up with him
I started working at OD Asset Management
in March 2003 I had just moved to to
London from there from Australia he was
extremely inappropriate in many ways
the physical attention with how he
looked at you unfortunately being on
that reception desk you are often on
your own and so that was you know great
opportunity for him to do whatever he
wanted to do and that's where the
majority of the massages occurred
they were quite forceful they would
start on your shoulders and move down
your ribs to try to touch your breasts
I remember vividly having to pin my arms
to my side and cover my chest so that
couldn't happen
it wasn't always possible to avoid being
you know whose presence
I was asked to sit next to him to open
the mail
and when I declined I was told I had to
sit there by another fund manager at the
time and that happened in a full floor
of trailers he started to stroke my leg
under the desk
when I moved away you know he laughed
and said I need to start enjoying things
like this
and I didn't know what to do in that
moment because if everybody condoned his
behavior and allowed that to happen what
could I do
by February we realized we would
potentially have enough to do a kind of
full-blown investigation we spoke to 13
women of the 13 women eight said that
they were sexually assaulted by Chris
bernodian
I was introduced to Mr Odie through
mutual friends in November 2021
I was being represented by a lawyer for
a legal dispute and it turned out it was
the same lawyer that Mr Odie had been
represented by he asked me if I liked
shooting pheasants I said I did and he
said I must invite you to come to one of
my shoots
it was a normal shooting weekend of
which I have been to many
at the end of the dinner everyone is
still sitting at the table Odie said to
me across the table let's go and sit
next door and I want you to bring me up
to speed on the court case
I picked up my glass of wine and we went
to a small room just next door to the
dining room
we discussed where we were with my legal
situation
we were in two chairs opposite the fire
and I got up to leave to go back
he
grabbed me and he pulled me onto his
knee
he groped my breasts he forced his
tongue into my mouth
I pushed him off and said what on Earth
are you doing
and then he took my hand by the wrist
and he forced it between his legs
and clamped it onto his erect penis
whilst my hand was being forced onto him
he said
this is how excited you make me feel
he did it by force I hadn't done
anything to give him any reason to think
it was okay to do what he was doing a
number of allegations were incredibly
violent one woman he assaulted her by
penetration with his fingers whilst
masturbating over her one incident was
so traumatic that I've blocked the
majority of it from my mind
I don't remember much but I remember
that at times he was on his knees he put
his hand up my shirt that he was trying
to touch my breasts that
my makeup was all over his shirt
and
I think there's a reason that I've
plotted it from my mind
within the walls of his firm it was an
Open Secret and so much so that we've
had plenty of women tell us within the
first week or two of joining that they
were warned don't get in the office lift
with Chris benody
his arrogance is just
extraordinary
how he has in such strange situations
environments not just in the workplace
but in restaurants for me at a dinner
party
he has continued to behave like this
a woman who's referred to in the article
as Emily alleged that the first time he
assaulted her he just wants to put his
hand inside her shirt and so he does so
the second time when he assaults her
she's sort of prepared for it she
screams so she's trying to leave a
meeting room that she's been having a
conversation with Odin and as she's
trying to leave he grabs her put his
hands on her hips and tries to drag her
back into the meeting room she shouts
Crispin no and when she emerges into the
hallway
she bumps into a senior male employee
and she's
you know convinced he was within an air
shot and he says absolutely nothing
there are definitely questions to be
asked about what senior figures at ODI
Asset Management knew or didn't know
they probably had a financial interest
in maintaining the status quo everybody
knew what was happening everybody knew
about his behavior one day I was forced
to go to lunch at the gavrosh with Odie
I was told that I had to go and I didn't
have a choice it had been in the
calendar for some time
and I couldn't say no to him when I
realized that I had no choice I
asked if I could bring along that other
receptionist to accompany me I didn't
feel safe and I did not want to be alone
with this man Odie was not happy with me
for inviting this other receptionist
along he said that I should direct that
in conversation to him and that I had no
social skills because I spoke to
somebody other than him he continued to
say
things like I would never be able to eat
at a restaurant like that if I wasn't
with him
that he has all the money and the power
that he is the boss
and my poor social skills were why I was
just a receptionist
so going to the going to the restaurant
was the final straw because
it added another level for me to be told
that because of
money and power and status that I could
be treated however
he liked
when when we returned for lunch
I remember being in such shock that I
sat at my desk and every person that
came down from that trading floor
would make some
jibe or joke about my lunch and what did
I do to annoy him
Odie has come back really angry I I have
no social skills
making complete fun out of this
situation
and that for me
was
just as bad there were lots of people in
senior positions at the firm who
absolutely knew what women said he was
doing to them
those who worked alongside him
protected him
that makes them complicit in this he had
enormous power enormous power as its
owner and founder his Partners
were not always comfortable challenging
him
he really held people's Fortunes in his
hands so the effect of that enormous
power in the company was to create a
culture of secrecy and silence Odie and
ODI Asset Management
completely got away
with hiding what had happened
they didn't acknowledge they never
apologized
they didn't care
it was more about silencing me so that
it didn't get out
we published on a Thursday
The Fallout from the investigation was
both rapid and immediate
it's been one of the quickest and most
decisive unravelings of a hedge fund
that I can remember
it was published early morning on the
8th of June by early afternoon that day
Morgan Stanley which is one of OD asset
Management's Cube Prime Brokers had
moved to sabotage with the firm a prime
book is a crucial for hedge funds to go
about their business because they offer
services like stock lending leverage
trade execution when Morgan Stanley cut
ties it then became untenable for OD
asset Management's other relationships
not to go the same way other firms sort
of fearing the reputation or Fallout
began reviewing and terminating their
relationship the French brokerage Exxon
Goldman Sachs followed Schroeder said
they were pulling their remaining
investments from The Firm we also
revealed that the UK Financial regulator
the financial conduct Authority was
widening its investigation into ODI he
and his firm became a toxic asset within
the city of London crucially it really
worries all the asset Management's
clients who know that without those
Banks the company simply can't do
business on the weekend then there was
another big bombshell Partners at OD
Asset Management said that they were
going to remove crispinody as a member
he suggested to the Ft that this is
something he would fight I put in a call
to Crispin and he gave this very
crispin-like response how they're going
to do that you've got to have a willing
buyer willing seller but then hung up at
the same time you had clients although
the asset management putting in
Redemption requests so asking to
withdraw their money they decided to
shutter the OD Swan fund blocking
redemptions from a number of funds to
something you only really see in quite
distressed situations then there was
another Milestone of when JP Morgan
which was the Prime broker but also the
custodian that safeguards the OD asset
managements and assets also began
terminating their relationship and this
was crucial because having a custodian
is a regulatory t on the Wednesday after
our story broke the treasury Select
Committee of MPS wrote the UK's
Financial Watchdog demanding to know
what action it had taken with respect to
Crispin Odin also on the Wednesday UBS
said it was going to sever its ties with
the fun
on the Thursday which is exactly a week
after our report first published the
company announced that it was looking to
break up
the company is now in the process of
transferring some of its funds and its
fund managers to other asset management
companies in effect dismantling one of
Britain's oldest asset management
companies I think it's probably closer
to a war room than a company at the
moment and how that company can go on
existing without Crispin is very hard to
see things are looking quite Bleak for
the firm too many institutions have cut
ties and I don't see them rushing back
anytime soon
Eddie was able to get away with this
behavior for decades
I think it speaks to a wider point
across many different Industries about
money and power and how people think
they are untouchable
with Wilson the company in the end it
wasn't the courts it wasn't the police
it wasn't the regulator it was a bunch
of journalists we have finally held
someone to accounts and that's benefited
the lives of many women who've been
quite seriously harmed by this guy the
impact he's had on them has lasted
decades in some cases these women
weren't listened to and so it has
affected me and it has affected the way
I think about everything
the system about where we stand and how
much we can trust and how we can be
protected because I now have daughters
and I don't want either of them to have
to go through what I did
and I wanted to contribute to positive
change to highlighting systems that
enable and normalize this behavior
um
because change is needed
he isn't just a man who allegedly
harassed and Abused women over many
years he's a man that activated the
scrutiny of the regulator the police the
FCA cannot just sit and turn a blind eye
or pretend in fact that they are doing a
good investigation when they are simply
not
they need to take these things more
seriously and they need to act more
promptly
the fact that we are
scared to go to the police because we
aren't going to be
believed or listened to is terrible
something really serious needs to change
so sexual assault wherever it occurred
is handled we do know that Chris been
threatened judicial action against the
FCA if it continued to pursue the sexual
misconduct line of inquiry so it's
possible they were intimidated by him
why we're able to go through a list of
former female employees and find them
and contact them and get some of them
just talk to us and the FCA can't is not
clear to me odie's performance has been
incredibly volatile he's had some
amazing years but often on a much
smaller asset base and there are
investors who've lost a lot of money
with him I think it speaks to a wider
point about the business model of the
hedge fund industry which appears to be
a heads I win Tales you lose he's still
got 600 million of his own money in the
funds it doesn't feel
like a complete sense of justice
we've watched his company crumble and
disintegrate hopefully
I feel that it's the right thing but it
wasn't the company that assaulted the
women
they may have aided and debetted him
he is the one who groped us
he is the one who needs to be held to
account I think the huge number of women
in our story did help it's a really hit
home but it is
depressing that it takes that number of
women I feel you know enormously
frustrated for the women who came first
there is power in numbers
but it's really telling of
how
far we have to go
when we only listen to a collective
voice
because my voice should have been enough
20 years ago I should have
many other voices I don't think it's
that women won't believe the vast
majority of people knew what ODI was
like I don't think they necessarily knew
the extremes of it or the links that he
went to the women I heard but they're
just ignored the Fallout since the Ft
investigation is something that I
never imagined could ever happen
it really highlights
how many more people including already
need to be held accountable
and what we need to do to create systems
that protect women
I am the mother of girls
this Behavior needs to be stopped
I don't want my children my daughters
going into a workplace and having to be
subjected to what he subjected to so
many of us too so many of us
foreign
[Music]